[Music]
more than a hundred years after his
creator was laid to rest Dracula
lived on as the most famous vampire in
history but this Transylvanian Noble
neither the first fictional vampire nor
the most popular of his time may have
remained buried in obscurity if not for
a twist of fate
Dracula's first appearance was in Bram
Stoker's 1897 novel of the same name but
that was far from the beginning of
vampire myth blood sucking monsters had
already been part of folklore for at
least 800 years it was Slavic folklore
that gave us the word vampire or appear
in old Russia the terms first known
written mention comes from the 11th
century vampire lore in the region
predated Christianity's arrival and
persisted despite the church's efforts
to eliminate pagan beliefs stories of
vampires originated from
misinterpretation of diseases such as
rabies and pellagra and decomposition in
the case of the latter gases swelling
the body and blood moving from the mouth
could make a corpse look like it had
recently been alive and feeding vampires
were described as bloated with overgrown
teeth and nails this gave rise to many
rituals intended to prevent the dead
from rising such as burying bodies with
garlic or poppy seeds as well as having
them staked burned or mutilated vampire
lore remains a local phenomenon until
the 18th century when Serbia was caught
in the struggle between two great powers
the Habsburg monarchy and Ottoman Empire
Austrian soldiers and government
officials observed and documented a
strange local burial ritual and their
reports became widely publicized the
resulting vampire hysteria got so out of
hand that in 1755 the Austrian Empress
was forced to dispatch her personal
physician he investigated and put an end
to the rumors by publishing a thorough
scientific refuge
the panic subsided but the vampire had
already taken root in Western Europe's
imagination spawning works like the
vampire in 1819 and Joseph Sheridan
lafon news Carmilla in 1872 this book
would greatly influence a young Irish
drama critic named Bram Stoker Stoker
who was born in Dublin in 1847 was
famously bedridden with an unknown
illness until the age of seven during
that time his mother told him folk tales
and true tales of horror including her
experiences during an outbreak of
cholera in 1832 there she described
victims buried alive in mass graves
later in his life Stoker went on to
write fantasy romance adventure stories
and in 1897 Dracula
although the book's main villain and
namesake is thought to be based on the
historical figure of Vlad the 3rd
Dracula or Vlad the Impaler the
Association is mostly just that they
share a name other elements and
characters were inspired directly and
indirectly by various works in the
Victorian era such as the mysterious
stranger the novel upon release was only
a moderate success in its day
nor was it even Stoker's most well-known
work mentioned only briefly in a 1912
obituary but a critical copyright battle
would completely change Dracula's fate
and catapult the character into literary
renown in 1922 a German studio adapted
the novel into the now classic silent
film Nosferatu without paying royalties
despite changes in character names and
minor plot points the parallels were
obvious and the studio was sued into
bankruptcy to prevent more play jurors
of attempts Stoker's Widow decided to
establish copyright over the stage
version of Dracula by approving a
production by family friend
Hamilton Dean although dooms adaptation
made drastic cuts to the story it became
a classic thanks largely to
Lagasse's performance on Broadway Lugosi
would go on to star in the 1931 film
version by Universal lending the
character many of his signature
characteristics and since then Dracula
has risen again in countless adaptations
finding eternal life far beyond the
humble pages of his birth
[Music]